okay uh welcome everyone to this uh last
session of the day and also of the
workshop
uh so we are very happy to start this
final session uh with uh robin neumayer
from carnegie mellon university and uh
rowan is going to talk to us about
quantitative fabric current inequalities
and uh well please robin take it away
all right
thanks very much for the introduction
and thanks to the organizers for putting
on a very nice workshop and for inviting
me to take part in it
um
yes i wish i could be there in person
it's it's been
a very interesting week for me watching
these talks i come
from a bit of a different community than
a lot of the the people
associated with this workshop but uh
it's been quite interesting to to watch
the talks
um
so
today i want to talk about some joint
work with my collaborators mark allen at
brigham young university and dennis
kravinsov at rutgers
um and okay as i mentioned i come from a
little bit different of a community so
i'm not really speaking about things
directly related to the topic of the
workshop but i'll be talking about uh
quantitative
quantitative estimates for faber cron
inequalities as well as some
applications to a certain monotonicity
formula used in free boundary problems
so
my hope here is
that i maybe can communicate some of the
main themes of of this line of work
which i think may be under the surface
also have some connections to the
broader themes of the workshop
so
i i guess also i should say please have
no hesitation about stopping and
interrupting me along the way to ask
questions as they arise
so uh
the fiber kron inequality
in the plane in r2 says the following
physically
says if you consider
drum heads
of a fixed area so if you have some
fixed amount of animal height or
whatever synthetic material and you're
building a drum
then
of all possible shapes a circular drum
head is the one that's going to produce
the vibration of lowest frequency
so a little bit more mathematically and
more generally the fabricron inequality
uh
involves the following so so when i say
the frequency of lower lowest vibration
uh we define this in the following way
so take some bounded open subset omega
of euclidean space of any dimension or
more generally in a romanian manifold
then the principal frequency or the
first eigenvalue of the dirichlet
laplacian
is defined well we'll denote it by
lambda 1 of omega and it's given by
minimizing the dirichlet energy
among
functions that vanish on the boundary of
omega and that are normalized have l2
norm equal to one
so this infimum is achieved and it's
achieved by a
function u omega which is the
corresponding first eigen function of
the laplacian with dirichlet boundary
data
okay so some basic properties so
this is an eigen function in the sense
that it solves the following eigenvalue
equation for the laplacian this
minimizer u omega solves minus laplace u
equals
lambda one
times u omega in the domain where again
this is the first eigenvalue that's the
minimum value with dirichlet boundary
conditions
so
if if you have some reasonably nice
domain for example if your domain is
connected so this is sufficient but not
necessary then
this function is going to be strictly
positive in the interior of the domain
and will also be unique
and what the faber kron inequality says
then in this more general setting
is that if you take any bounded and open
subset of euclidean space
then the first eigenvalue of omega is
greater than or equal to the first
eigenvalue of the corresponding ball
of the same volume as omega and in fact
equality holds here if and only if omega
is some translation of this ball and
this is up to a set of capacity zero
so let me make a comment here
the
the same exact inequality holds for
subsets of the round sphere
and of hyperbolic space so here
in those settings when we say ball we
mean geodesic ball or a ball with
respect to the geodesic distance
uh in all of these cases the fabricron
inequality or the minimality of balls
here for the first eigenvalue is just a
consequence of the fact that balls are
iso-parametric sets
for every volume
so the main question that i'm interested
in today is that of stability for the
faber-cron inequality so i want to ask
the following question
suppose i have some domain omega
and the first eigenvalue is equal to
that of a ball of the same volume
plus a little bit
plus epsilon then
two things
is omega
close to a ball in some geometrically
meaningful sense
and similarly is its corresponding first
eigenvalue eigenfunction close to that
of a ball
and i want to understand this in a
quantitative sense
so
uh this type of result so before i even
get into the results let's think about
two different ways to interpret
this sort of quantitative stability
result for for a geometric inequality
like the fibre cron inequality
so the first interpretation is you can
think you've started at the ground state
you've started the ball and you inject
epsilon
amount of energy
into into this set in this case the
energy is the first dirichlet eigenvalue
uh then if you've if you've perturbed
the energy by epsilon
what we hope to show is some sort of
quantitative estimate that says then
this corresponding set is perturbed
at most by
some modulus of continuity involving
epsilon epsilon to some power alpha in
fact uh both in terms of the symmetric
difference
between omega and the closest ball so
this shaded blue region the volume of
the symmetric difference
and also
a distance that measures the difference
between the first eigen function of a
ball which is some radially symmetric
function and that on this domain
another way that you can read a
quantitative stability result of this
type is
as a statement about the
energy profile
of
the first eigenvalue functional as a
function on sets
so uh
you can think if we here i've from the
previous slide replaced uh epsilon by
epsilon to the one over alpha
if we prove a statement like
whenever the first eigenvalue is equal
to that of the ball plus one over or
epsilon to the one over alpha
implies the distance between omega and
the ball the nearest ball is of order
epsilon
we can think of this in the following
way here in the schematic picture i've
drawn
in this two-dimensional axis the
infinite dimensional space of subsets of
rn
normalized to have volume say one
and along this axis i've drawn the class
of minimizers that is translations of
balls so we can identify this really
with euclidean space just every point of
where this ball is centered
uh so a statement like this a
quantitative stability estimate like
this gives a
modulus of growth of the energy of the
first eigenvalue away from this class of
minimizers says the energy grows at
least like
uh
like epsilon or distance to the alpha
okay so uh
so a little bit more generally
not just focused on the fabric on
inequality but
a lot of my research program focuses on
quantitative stability estimates and
various different kinds of geometric and
functional inequalities
and people study these things because
they're useful uh they're they're
interesting from the viewpoint of the
calculus variations but they
they also end up being quite useful in
various different applications in
different parts of mathematics so let me
share with you
a couple of general motivations and
applications for
quantitative stability estimates for
functional and geometric inequalities
more broadly uh and then later in this
talk we'll talk about a specific
application of the new faber cron
stability results that we'll prove
so
one
nice type of application of quantitative
stability estimates uh comes in
understanding ground states or energy
minimizers for
complicated energy functionals so in
some cases like
for the first dirichlet eigenvalue
simple symmetrization arguments will
tell us that balls are minimizers but uh
sometimes
the situation is much more complicated a
nice example of this comes from work of
canoe foreign in 2014
where they studied the liquid drop model
coming from nuclear physics which
describes the
the equilibrium shape of atomic nuclei
and here they used a quantitative
stability result
for the isoparametric inequality the
isoparametric problem
in order to prove that balls are the
unique energy minimizers
for small mass in this liquid drop model
so stability was a tool to characterize
energy minimizers
so another
nice type of application
uh
comes
in the form of using stability estimates
to give effective approximations for
variational problems so an example here
comes from uh
a paper of garcia trios murray and thor
the first author gave a very nice talk
here earlier this week
uh and in this paper the authors
consider a
clustering method for finite data sets
sampled from distributions on on some
continuous domain on some continuous uh
romanian manifold
and here they apply a recent
quantitative stability estimate for the
isoparametric problem here on romanian
manifolds
in order
to prove high probability convergence
rates for clusters formed from
finite data sets as the number of
sampled points tends to infinity
okay and another type of application of
quantitative stability estimates that
i'll mention uh comes in the form of
rates of convergence
in parabolic flows so here a nice
example is work of carlin and fagali
where they use
they they prove some new quantitative
stability estimates for a sobolev type
uh energy uh for galliardo nirenberg
sobolev inequalities
and they apply this to establish
convergence rates for the keller sigal
equation an equation that models
population density for bacteria over
time
okay so uh so all in all these kind of
quantitative stability estimates are are
useful in various settings and like i
mentioned at the
in the latter part of this talk we'll
see uh an application of the results
that i'm going to talk about
okay but so let's let's return to the
fabricron inequality
so
in 2015 there's a very nice
quantitative stability estimate that was
proven for the faber-cron inequality uh
it's due to brosco de felipe and
felichkov and it says the following it
says if you take any domain omega in
euclidean space it's open and bounded
then
if the first eigenvalue is equal to the
first eigenvalue of a ball of the same
volume plus epsilon
then
the volume of the symmetric difference
again that's this shaded error the
volume of this blue shaded area the
points in one set but not the other it's
at most of order epsilon to the power
one-half
uh and this power one half in fact is is
optimal so in terms of this uh energy
profile picture this corresponds to
quadratic energy growth away from the
class of minimizers away from volts
so so this is a very nice result there's
one drawback here which is the following
this comes from the
small distinction that uh
the fabricron inequality
or rather the first eigenvalue more
generally detects
uh
changes in sets up to sets of capacity
zero
whereas uh this volume of the symmetric
difference it detects
uh changes up to sets of la big measure
zero
and so
in this way
uh from their estimate you might have
uh epsilon positive that is to say you
might have some
set with uh
first eigenvalue strictly bigger than
that of the ball the same volume
but
it's symmetric difference uh is the same
or the symmetric difference with the
ball is equal to zero so a nice example
of this would be a slit domain you take
a ball in any dimension and you cut out
uh
a
lower
one a hyper plane you cut out a
hyperplane uh or half a hyper plane
from from this set
the resulting domain omega is going to
have strictly larger first eigenvalue
okay so so we see then this quantitative
stability estimate is uh
although it's it's sharp in this optimal
power we're sort of not detecting the
right types of uh the right size of
modifications of sets with respect to
this sort of distance
so just a side remark here in this kind
of example or any example in which uh
you modify your domain
or you take a ball and you modify it so
that the first eigenvalue is strictly
bigger than that of the ball
then the difference between the
corresponding first eigen function and
that of a ball in l2 is strictly
positive
so
the sort of the main result that i want
to share with you today then is the
following so as i mentioned this is
joint work with alan and kravenzov uh
from this past summer
and we show the following so
take a bounded open subset of euclidean
space as before or
hyperbolic space or the round sphere so
any
spaces simply connected space forms
suppose you have suppose that this set
has first eigenvalue
that is
equal to the first eigenvalue of the
ball of the same volume plus epsilon
then
the difference between their
corresponding eigenfunctions
uh in l2 plus
the volume of their symmetric difference
is at most
of order epsilon to the power one-half
so here on on any of these space forms
we're controlling again the size of this
symmetric difference this blue shaded
area
but also the l2 difference between
eigen functions on these domains
okay and once again uh
this
rate this this power epsilon to the
power one half is is optimal it cannot
be replaced by any
larger exponent
okay so uh so with respect to oh geez
okay oh i really scrolled okay so with
respect to this previous
just a clarification question so how do
uh given that these two functions are
eigen functions are defined in different
domains how do you compare them in l2
you extend by zero extend by zero yes so
yes thank you
so here we're using the fact that these
have dirichlet boundary data so exactly
just
extend them by zero and then this
integral is taken over the
entire space say
m whether this this manifold m is
euclidean space hyperbolic space or the
round sphere
well we're here any any further
questions before i carry on
okay
so um
so
just to to mention so so there are two
new features of this result relative to
the one of brosco de felipes and uh
velishkov that i mentioned before the
first is
that this quantitative estimate gives
control of the eigenfunction difference
between these two domains
excuse me and also
we extend this result to the sphere and
hyperbolic space where this is the first
quantitative stability result of any
sort at least that holds in the
generality of of all sets there were
some results of ovula uh from the early
2000's involving convex
stability estimates among convex sets of
these spaces
but so both of these two generalizations
were not just
for fun let's say uh they were both
crucial in the application that we had
in mind to this monotonicity formula in
the study of free boundary problems
so i want to say a couple of words about
the proof of this quantitative stability
estimate hopefully uh
in a direction that might be of interest
to to some people in this crowd
so
the basic proof scheme
which is sort of the
go-to
proof strategy for quantitative
stability estimates in the setting of
geometric inequalities
is a technique known as the selection
principle so this was something
introduced by chicoleze and leonardi
in the context of the isoparametric
inequality from 2012
and this scheme has two steps so the
first step is a
local analysis and this is the portion
of the proof that i'll say actually a
couple of details about so here you want
to prove this desired quantitative
stability estimate among small smooth
perturbations of the ball
and this second step then which i won't
say anything further about is a
reduction step that says okay
in order to prove quantitative stability
for all
bounded open sets it actually suffices
to prove it for those local
perturbations
and this step is always based in
regularity theory for for minimizers of
some carefully constructed functional
related to the main one so so in this
case a a certain perturbation of the
first eigenvalue functional
but so
i'd like to share some details about
this local analysis step so more
specifically what this step entails is
the following
suppose you have some set omega and you
know that the boundary of omega
is a small
c to alpha graph
over the boundary of the ball okay so
so here i've got some ball in red and we
suppose that our set omega looks like
this so it's uh
it's just a smooth its boundary is a
smooth perturbation of the boundary of
the ball
this is a ball that has the same volume
as omega and moreover we have translated
these so that
the very center of omega is equal to the
very center of the ball okay so here
i've drawn a euclidean space picture
if you want to keep in mind that that
we're also proving this on the sphere
and on hyperbolic space here's a
an analogous picture on the sphere now
our balls are spherical caps and again
we're considering a function omega whose
whose boundary is a small perturbation
the goal now is to prove
the quantitative stability estimate we
want just for this class of sets so i
want to show okay if omega is like this
then
if i know the first eigenvalue is that
of the ball plus a little bit plus
epsilon
then the l2 distance difference between
my eigenfunctions and plus the symmetric
difference between omega and the ball is
at most of order
epsilon to the power one-half
so
the key point here is that uh
you're able to write all of the relevant
geometric quantities in terms of the
parameterizing function so so we assumed
that the boundary of omega is
a small c2 alpha graph let me call the
on the boundary of the ball let me call
this function psi okay so boundary of
omega is given by one plus
psi of x pushing in the x direction
that's the normal direction
for x on the boundary of the ball so
here then psi is a function on the
boundary of the ball
with small c to alpha norm
so
my entire
uh
everything my first eigen let's start
with yeah the first eigenvalue of omega
i'm able to write this in terms of my
parameterizing function c
so let me go ahead and do a taylor
expansion of this quantity so at order
zero my taylor expansion is just going
to give me the first eigenvalue of the
ball
at first order i get
the first variation whatever it is
at second order i get the second
variation whatever it is plus higher
order terms
so
the
the ball is a minimizer of the
first eigenvalue so in particular it's a
critical point and so this first order
term
is going to vanish this first variation
is going to be
zero
and so
the gap between my first eigenvalues
lambda 1 omega minus lambda 1 of the
ball up to higher order terms is just
the second variation of the first
eigenvalue at a ball in the direction c
c that's what i have in my second order
of the taylor expansion
so really the key point now is to show
that the
second variation
uh of the first eigenvalue of the ball
in directions
c
controls
the h1 half norm of this parameterizing
function c
squared
okay
from there it's not so hard to show that
this h1 half norm squared
controls the two geometric quantities
that we want to control the distance
between eigenfunctions and the symmetric
difference between the sets
okay
so so let me say a word or two about uh
this key estimate
which i've called star so i want to show
the second variation i want to
show some some
quantitative stability at the level of
the second variation
so
we want to do a
a spectral analysis here a uh and okay
so so
so the idea is
let's write down this second variation
it's a
given by the integral over the boundary
of a ball
of c times l of c where l is
the the differential operator that i get
in the second variation so it's a first
order non-local operator
it's a bit nasty but you can write it
down
so
it's also a
an operator with a discrete spectrum and
so we can write down
the uh
this expression in terms of
the
l2 basis of the eigenfunctions of this
operator l
so i write this as the sum from k equals
zero to infinity of
beta i these are the eigenvalues of this
operator l
times a i squared these are the fourier
coefficients okay the the coefficients
for this expansion
on this l2 basis
so
there are a couple of things i can
compute explicitly
from
the volume constraint so the fact that
my set omega has the same volume as as a
ball uh
this coefficient corresponding to my
zeroth eigenvalue
is
in in fact that it's an eigenvalue with
uh with value zero this corresponding
coefficient is going to be
equal to zero
uh
moreover
the fact that i've fixed my very center
is going to tell me explicitly that
these
first these next n coefficients
in my fourier expansion
are also equal to zero
this function c parameterizing my
boundaries orthogonal to translations
which are
in the next eigenspace
and so really what this means is that my
my second variation is given by the sum
from
k equals n plus 1 to infinity of
my
corresponding eigenvalues times the
fourier coefficients squared
and so
here's uh
so so it's at this point that we want to
find a gap in the spectrum of this
operator l okay we would like to say
that uh the next
eigenvalues the first eigenvalue that's
appearing in this expansion is actually
strictly positive unlike the the
eigenvalues corresponding to
volume and to dilations and translations
okay and so in the case on euclidean
space you're actually able to appeal to
explicit formulas uh that tell you that
this next eigenvalue
of your second variation operator
is going to be something strictly
positive okay
from which point you can say okay your
second variation
is equal to this sum from n plus one
to infinity of beta i alpha i squared
which is bounded from below by some
uniform constant times the l2 norm of
your function
okay we really wanted to control the h1
norm squared but it's just a small trick
to upgrade from there
the problem is that on
the sphere and on hyperbolic space
these explicit formulas aren't available
so in fact on
on these space forms unlike in euclidean
space we don't even have a closed form
expression for the first eigenvalue of a
spherical of a of a geodesic ball so for
example a spherical cap on the sphere
so
in order to find this
spectral gap
at the the appropriate place that says
if our parameterizing function is
orthogonal to dilations and translations
then the next eigenvalue comes with a
strictly bigger eigen function or eigen
function comes with a strictly bigger
eigenvalue
we use
a method that we introduced that we were
calling it
implicit spectral analysis
so the idea here is that we use the
maximum principle in order to
deduce the existence of a spectral gap
in this operator whose spectrum we can't
get an explicit handle on
so
the basic
idea here is that
using the symmetry of our minimizers
balls
we know that all of the eigen functions
of this second variation operator
are spherical harmonics they're eigen
functions of
the laplacian on the boundary of the
ball
so those eigenvalues the eigenvalues of
the laplacian for these guys are
explicitly known
what we don't know explicitly are the
eigenvalues of this operator l
corresponding to each of these
eigenfunctions
uh the the eigenvalue is determined by
the
the
derivative of a solution to a certain
ode
okay so the i eigenvalue of l
is given by uh
the up to a constant the derivative of
this function f i at one
where f is a function on the interval
zero one
solving an ode okay a second order ode
whose explicit form is not so important
the only thing i want to point out is
that it involves the
corresponding eigenvalue
of
for the laplacian on the sphere
something that's explicit
and so
although we're not able to actually
compute what these eigenvalues are
um
we're able to use a maximum principal
argument uh comparing solutions
of these two ode of the of the odes for
varying
values of
the eigenvalue of the laplacian on the
sphere
and basically deduce that whenever you
have a spec a gap in the spectrum
for the laplacian on the sphere there's
a also a gap in the spectrum for this
operator l
okay so in particular
uh
for the first
for i running from one up to n
the
eigenvalues of the the eigenvalues of
the plotion or the so the spherical the
spherical harmonics their correspond to
translations the eigenvalues are the
same for each of those
and so the corresponding eigenvalues in
the context of our operator l are also
the same in fact they're equal to zero
but when you take the next eigenvalue
so you're when you when you take the
next i
uh you get a gap in the spectrum for the
spherical harmonics
and so
then using the maximum principle
comparing these two ode solutions you in
fact get a gap in the spectrum in the
corresponding operator l
okay and so so in this way we're able to
conclude uh the quantitative stability
estimate among sets that are small
perturbations of
of
balls
okay so um
let me say
one or two words just in the last uh a
couple of minutes about the main
application of this results so
the context that we're interested in is
uh
something called the alt kafarelli
friedman monotonicity formula so this is
a monotonicity formula that's really
important in the study of certain free
boundary problems the obstacle problem
and two-phase free boundary problems
really it's a fact though about
pairs of non-negative sub-harmonic
functions so the basic setup here is
that uh
you take any two
functions you uh v1 and v2
that are non-negative
and
are subharmonic in their supports so vi
is sub-harmonic where it's strictly
positive
and the supports of these two
functions are disjoint okay and let's
suppose that the origin is in the
intercept in the boundary of both of
their
posit the the boundary of their
positivity sets
okay so kind of situations you can have
in mind
would be if
v1 and v2 are both just truncated linear
functions so a linear function here a
linear function of possibly a different
slope over here
uh
meeting at a hyperplane interface so
this is somehow the model situation
um
but
more generally you can have
other sort of configurations you can
have an interface between these two
domains that's like a cone
and say v1 and v2 are the corresponding
harmonic functions that vanish on the
boundary of these two domains
or you can have
really nasty behaved uh
domains omega 1 and omega 2 and really
whatever sub-harmonic functions you want
uh
on those two domains so so there's no
real assumption of of well there's no
assumption of the regularity of the
interface or or niceness of these
functions
uh and what the this monotonicity
formula says though is for any pair of
such functions
consider the following formula
j of r so so r here is a scaling
parameter
it takes a slightly different form in
higher dimensions
but in two dimensions this
monotonicity formula is simply the
average
of
the dirichlet energy of v1 over a ball
of radius r times the average of the
dirichlet energy of a ball
uh of v2 on a ball of radius r
and what this m what this monotonicity
formula says is that
this thing is monotone it's strictly
decreasing as or well it's decreasing as
r tends to zero or in other words it's
increasing as a function of r
and moreover there's a rigidity
associated to this uh
if so if the limit of this monotonicity
formula is your ten to zero is positive
then your monotonicity formula is
constant if and only if you're in this
model situation of two uh
two truncated
linear solutions
okay uh in the interest of time let me
just
uh
go quickly to to the point
uh
we we apply
maybe i'll just draw draw a picture we
apply our main quantitative so the main
application of this quantitative
stability estimate for the faber-cron
inequality is the following we give a
condition
in terms of this monotonicity formula
enabled in order to ensure that uh
a pair of sub-harmonic functions like we
had before
have unique
have unique blow-ups so if you start
okay something's going wrong with my
pencil um
so if you start to
rescale
these functions in the following way so
if you just start zooming in and
rescaling these functions in a lipschitz
manner
we give
an optimal condition in terms of this
monotonicity formula to tell you that
these guys are going to blow up
to a unique have a unique uh blow up to
two linear functions with a hyperplane
tangent uh hyperplane interface so in
particular this gives you a condition
guaranteeing
a tangent plane for the interface at
zero at the origin between these two uh
subharmonic functions
okay so
anyway uh i am i am out of time so
thanks very much for your attention
uh thank you very much uh rowan are
there any questions
so thank you very much for this very
interesting talk in fact i have two
short questions and the first one is is
there any hope that you can get a
statement on the house of distance
between the set and the ball or could
the could there be situations where the
the set has
very large spikes with small measure and
the second question is can you
is there any hope or do you have any
ideas how to translate your results to
non-linear differential operators for
instance studying the minimal eigenvalue
of the p laplacian operator
okay two nice questions okay so so the
first question about could this be
upgraded to hausdorff
distance
the answer there is
no so so you can
construct examples
uh where you take so so we should go and
dimension oh boy i'm having
so in dimension
higher than
two
let's take a
a ball
say an r3
you can add on some
sort of
thin tentacles
in
uh in a way and you can make explicit
constructions where the
first eigenvalue of course it will will
grow but only a small amount
whereas you can make the hausdorff
distance then by by taking this say this
neck to be
very skinny you can take you can make
the hausdorff distance between your set
omega
and the nearest ball arbitrarily large
uh well keeping the the first eigenvalue
very close to that of a ball
now
for the second question actually um
yes for okay so so for something like
the first eigenvalue of the p laplacian
uh you do have a similar
type of
uh fabricron
type inequality
that that will say that you're
i don't know how to denote this the
first eigenvalue of the peel applausion
which okay
it is just just given by the
minimization of the rayleigh quotient uh
is again minimized by
a ball
and there's
so inter on just euclidean space and
just for the
symmetric difference there's a stability
result
here that is due to
uh fusco
[Music]
and zhang
wherein on euclidean space they show
that this gap in the
peel plus eigenvalues uh controls the
symmetric difference of omega to the
nearest ball
now so
so that's to say they add an error term
that's like c plus symmetric difference
okay to the nearest ball of omega
squared
so using our techniques i think that
this results could be
also generalized to the sphere or
hyperbolic space
now in terms of controlling the
difference between the eigen functions
this is something that uh it's
for
in the portion of the sort of step two
the regularity step that i didn't
discuss at all
uh
it already becomes quite
so the regularity theory becomes quite
delicate because of the
because we're trying to control the
eigenvalue the eigenfunction difference
um
running the same kind of so so trying to
establish then the same type of
regularity estimates where
essentially you you would have a appeal
applausing replacing the laplacian
here and there
okay would be would be significantly
more difficult so so i'm not sure about
that but i do think uh so so
generalizing this results to
the sphere and hyperbolic space would be
quite manageable using our techniques
okay great thank you very much
hello uh
sorry if i missed it but what's a tight
example for your inequality
the refined one
uh also if you if you take uh
if you take a uh
sequence of of like small small
ellipsoidal perturbations of okay well i
don't know what's it if you take take
the ball and just kind of perturb it so
take a sequence of ellipsoids
uh just with
with
eccentricity like one plus epsilon and
let epsilon tend to zero
then
the here uh these guys are going to be
sharp in the inequality so so these will
exactly uh separate the energy separates
exactly quadratically with respect to
this distance
and in the likewise also i mean so so
here it's kind of a euclidean picture
but also on the sphere and hyperbolic
space essentially if you take
ellipsoidal perturbations of
the g of geodesic balls you can do this
in coordinates and find the same that
this this is sharp
uh okay are there any questions from our
virtual participants perhaps
any questions here in the audit term yes
there's another
question thank you uh so i have a rather
naive question um
i feel like in the sampling community
i'm more familiar with uh sampling
that's that's a pancara inequality so i
wonder if there is some like what has
the connection with the panka inequality
here which is also like a spectral gap
but for different um set of functions
wait i'm sorry i'm sorry could you
repeat the question
so
what are the link between this uh uh
inequality the power with the poker
inequality
okay
okay so so
the
punker so the first
let's see maybe there are there are two
connections and and so there are
different different eigenvalues at
different levels that i was discussing
in the talk so so the most
basic connection is okay so so
so given
your a domain omega say bounded
and open
uh
we defined its first
dirichlet eigenvalue this
is the
punch array
constant
for
uh the dirichlet boundary conditions
so that's to say
for
any
function u in
h1
0 omega so that vanishes on the boundary
the
gradient u
squared
is greater than or equal to
this punch ray constant times u squared
um
so
so in this way what the fiber kron
inequality says
is that
among sets of a fixed
domain balls have the smallest
punch array constant
for the dirichlet for dirichlet
conditions
um
now within the proof so so
the
within the proof we also so this was
maybe connection one
within the proof we established this uh
we established the existence of a
spectral gap for this
second variation
operator uh
and so this gives rise to then the
following uh
punk array inequality
for
functions defined on the boundary of the
ball so so
in
the proof
we show that
for a function
i'm going to use the same notation just
so if we have some function c
in
in
h1 half of
okay let's find let's just say h1 of the
boundary of the ball
then
and uh
if
c is orthogonal in l2 to
translations okay meaning so if c
integrates to zero
and if
at least let me write this in euclidean
space if c integrated against coordinate
functions
is zero
on the boundary of the bone
then it satisfies the following punch
array inequality
involving the
so
it satisfies cl c is greater than or
equal to
a constant times
the h1 half norm
oxy
where this is
so this is like a first order so
this is like a first order quantity um
so somehow an indirect sort of punk ray
inequality if you like i mean
so maybe maybe this looks more like a
punker inequality if we simply put l2
here
and so this is
some kind of uh
this is
so this is morally like uh
uh
half derivative
integrated and squared
so this is morally a sort of h1 half
norm type of quantity because i say that
because this is a
first order operator applied to c
times c so if you think you integrate
half the derivative by parts then this
is like a
squared norm of a half derivative
okay thank you does that answer your
question
yeah yeah thank you
all right so in the interest of time we
can conclude here so thank you very much
robin again for for this very nice talk
and
let's have a five minute break and then
we can continue our program
thank you